llegó el momento de hablar de números de
la información económica en france 24 me
acompaña en nuestro estudio nuestro
compañero jorge hurtado jorge vamos a
comenzar hablando del fondo monetario
internacional porque afirmaron que ellos
no tienen problemas con rusia así lo
dijo que kristalina georgieva quien es
la gerente directora de este organismo
internacional asegura que la única forma
de sacar a rusia el organismo es que la
mayoría de países se pongan de acuerdo y
así lo solicite el organismo que
suspendió su oficina en moscú espera una
mala recesión en rusia y un impacto en
los países vecinos
el fondo aprobó el 10 de marzo un
financiamiento de emergencia de 1400
millones de dólares para ucrania y
evalúa el impacto para la economía
global que tendrá esta guerra escuchemos
la intervención de la gerente del fmi
durante la cumbre mundial de gobiernos
en dubai
ports la junta directiva solo puede
suspenderlo si los miembros del fondo
dicen que lo reconocemos a este gobierno
en particular y esa es una decisión muy
difícil richard porque todos sabemos que
para que esta guerra termine tiene que
haber diálogo no va a suceder sin el
cuidado o rage vamos a asia por que
shanghai anuncios y medidas para tratar
de abordar el confinamiento y 5 acto
económico esa ciudad que tiene un centro
financiero con 26 millones de habitantes
vivió hoy su segundo día de bloqueo
confinamientos decretados por las
autoridades los el gobierno de la ciudad
propuso nuevas medidas para tratar de
apoyar a los negocios afectados que
incluyen exenciones de alquiler y
descuentos de impuestos se ofrecerán
reembolsos que reducirán la carga fiscal
de las empresas venga hasta 22.000
millones de dólares asimismo pidieron a
las plataformas de línea que reduzcan el
costo de sus servicios y a las empresas
de telecomunicaciones que brinden
servicios gratuitos la bolsa de valores
de shanghai mantiene el mínimo de
personal y otras empresas continúan
trabajando en modo remoto tienen la
motor se sigue produciendo porque
mantiene a sus trabajadores durmiendo
inclusive dentro de la fábrica esto
según reitera el cierre de esta ciudad
pone más presión a la economía global
que enfrenta altas cifras de inflación
derivada de la pandemia y ahora agravada
con la guerra en ucrania este viernes
comienza el mes sagrado para los
musulmanes del ramadán y la guerra en
ucrania está teniendo implicaciones en
este periodo sagrado así en varios
países de medio oriente están
enfrentando el alza en el costo de los
alimentos por la interrupción del
suministro y la inflación a las puertas
del inicio del ramadán el mes sagrado de
los musulmanes los precios de los
productos como la harina o la sémola
aumentaron a nivel mundial y hay
carencia de algunos alimentos básicos en
medio oriente por ejemplo la familia
egipcia suelen abastecerse de productos
alimenticios antes del mes sagrado
comprando frutas exóticas golosinas y
otros alimentos especiales para este
ramadán en egipto la tasa de inflación
interanual aumentó al 10% en febrero una
situación similar viven en la franja de
gaza- que reciben ayuda de los países
europeos y de los donantes pero que
ahora es están volcados de atender la
guerra en ucrania escuchamos un poco de
las modos las repercusiones de la crisis
ucraniana y la consiguiente subida de
precios están afectando a la población
que sufre unas condiciones de vida
difíciles la tasa de desempleo es más
alta que nunca a un 49 por ciento y el
umbral de pobreza ha superado el 50 por
ciento el 80 por ciento de los
ciudadanos de la franja de gaza dependen
de la ayuda la gente se enfrenta a
cargas adicionales que le impiden
satisfacer sus necesidades en el ramadán
de este año
borge y esta guerra obviamente también
tiene un impacto en américa latina' así
desde ayer en ecuador unos 500
productores de banano se manifestaron
por la caída del precio y la
interrupción de varios suministros los
productores piden a las autoridades que
se declarara una emergencia en el sector
según ellos cada semana han dejado de
vender entre cuatro mil y cinco mil
cajas por falta de transporte las
sanciones impuestas a rusia por la
invasión a ucrania paralizaron la salida
de la fruta desde los puertos europeos
hasta el de sant petersburgo la
organización que aglutina el gremio
estima que desde el inicio del conflicto
las pérdidas llegan a los 10 millones de
dólares ante la falta de la salida del
banano el precio a nivel interno se fue
a pique el ministerio de agricultura
fijó el precio en 625 dólares pero los
productores aseguran que en el mercado
se está negociando a 150 dólares el
banano es uno de los principales
productos de exportación de ecuador
después del petróleo y el camarón jorge
el momento de hablar de los indicadores
económicos iniciamos con wall street que
cerró en verde animado por los supuestos
intercambios entre una negociación
pacífica entre rusia y ucrania
esas conversaciones hicieron que las
bolsas europeas cerraran también en
positivo y en américa latina' el mercado
brasileño tuvo su mejor desempeño en los
últimos siete meses y reaccionó de forma
positiva a la baja de los precios de las
materias primas fue reportado con la
información económica muchísimas gracias
gracias también ustedes quédense en la
pantalla de france 24 y también en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
[Música]